okay chair we're ready
thank you good morning everybody and
welcome to this uh
latest meeting the trafford covered 19
public engagement board
attendances uh number one on the agenda
i am
not advised of any apologies uh
today uh are there any at all late
apologies
no other apologies research thank you
fabiola and
secondly on the agenda is declarations
of interest are there any declarations
of interest in any of the agenda items
by members present today
item three minutes of the last meeting
can i take them as read and as an
accurate record
and the actions that were in the uh
on the minutes have been uh
issue that i was i had sent my apologies
for that meeting because i was attending
the national holocaust memorial
so you need to be that recorded please
thank you
uh can we arrange for that fabiola for
an addendum for the next set of minutes
please
i will thank you thank you for that uh
if there are no actions of rising on
those minutes then can we therefore move
to magenta item four
this morning which is the um
update on the current cobra situation in
traffic from eleanor i do understand
eleanor
that you intend to bring a set of slides
to this meeting we thank you for the
report which i hope everybody has read
which is usually
very comprehensive so over to you and
the slides thank you
hey thanks very much so i thought we'd
start we'd use today's meeting to give
everybody an update on the work we're
doing in trafford
and it's really um we've talked
previously about the additional work
we're wanting to do in some areas and
getting
additional community engagement in our
work
so what we've done is we've put together
a set of slides which
are um in a really in part um
the work it was work we were doing
anyway but it's given that the operation
eagle operation eagle work that has been
going on
in manchester that people may be aware
of has given us an added impetus to
make sure that the work that we do in
the north trafford
area particularly the area that borders
with manchester
is absolutely clear and focused at this
time because we're concerned that
otherwise people in the area
may have some concerns so if i start by
i think we're slightly having problems
with um loading the
full file so i'll just um i'll describe
what
um the current situation is and what
operation eagle is in case people on the
board aren't aware so currently in
trafford as you know just this general
position
are our rates are still higher than we'd
like and what we're seeing at the end
with each lockdown is that our rates
start coming that they do come down and
they're very definitely the lockdowns
work
getting rates down but this time they
are coming down more slowly
and that's the same across the whole of
greater manchester and from being below
the rates of the
of england before christmas our rates
are now
above um the england average um
and there does seem to be quite a strong
link to between deprivation
levels of deprivation and speed of which
the rates come down
obviously for us in that trafford that
gives us particular concerns about the
north trafford area
and the rates there remaining remaining
higher
so um of our five
wards with our highest rates at the
moment i mean again we've got ernst
and we've got some mary's so in the west
and in um
uh the center center of trafford those
three
those wards also have rates of 300 per
hundred thousand
but longford stratford and clifford all
have rates over 300 per hundred thousand
at the moment
um so i do want people to be very aware
that we can
and we continue to have rates in every
ward over 100
100 000 which is higher than the who
level of um that we should be expressing
concern so we are not we are absolutely
not out of the woods
and we really do need to make sure that
we're all doing everything we can
to reduce our covert risk at the moment
including working from home wherever
possible
so operation eagle which people may have
heard about
um is being established in manchester
and it's a surge testing response
to us an identified geographical area
within manchester
and that's because um a few cases
of new variants of covid have been found
in um in manchester so covert because
it's a virus it does mutate
um some viruses some viruses
mutate more quickly than others um and
covid seemed to be quite stable for
quite a long time
but you'll know that there was a new
variant that was found in the southeast
of england before christmas
um the kent variation which has been
more transmittable than the previous
our previous covid and that is now the
dominant strain in trafford
and across the country the
new variant there's since then there's
been a further mutation
um in liverpool they have cases of the
original covid with a new variation
a new variant on one of the protein
spikes which
i'm not an immunologist but it's called
a 484k
variation um you may have heard of that
and
that variation makes it both more
transmittable
and it doesn't give such a strong
antibody response
so in liverpool what they've been doing
is trying to do
their test it they found some cases and
they've basically set a
a geographical area of 10 000 people
where they're doing
enhanced testing offering pcr testing
which is the normal
testing if you'd have when you're
symptomatic but that's for 10 000 people
in a particular
defined area and you go for the test and
if it's positive that's then um
genomically sequenced so that they can
see if it's the same variation to see
to try basically the idea is to find as
many cases
as you can get those people to isolate
and stop that wider spread of that new
variant
the variant that's been found in
manchester
is linked to one that's also been found
in bristol
and that variant also has the 484
um variation but instead of it being a
variation on the
original covet it's a variation on the
kent covid
so the already more transportable one so
that's why people are worried about it
there's no evidence that it makes people
more ill
and it also is not thought to stop the
vaccine from working so this should not
undermine
anyone's confidence in the vaccination
program but the idea is by finding the
variation these
if we so manchester have put a um
to find the geographical area based on
patterns of behavior
um in the area among the in the area
where they
the cases have been found so that they
can test everybody the same as they're
doing in liverpool they're doing the
same in bristol
um testing everybody in that immediate
area they've identified i think about
15 000 households
in that area it takes in places like
part of mmu
and also the asda and hume so you can
see that you'd
have quite a big catchment area for for
people using
using those sites and they're offering
that testing to everybody
in in the area in that defined area
so that they can see if they've got any
further cases
get those people to isolate and
hopefully stamp out
that this variation in terms of anybody
using that area or shopping or working
in that area if you work or study or
live in that area you're offered testing
you don't need to worry about going
through that area no other
you know it's just the usual covert
precautions nobody else is on an
additional lockdown for that area
it is simply to try and find these cases
and
as i say people shouldn't be worried
that they are going to be more ill
because of that
and the reason it's relevant to us is
because it's about at the
one of the edges of the area under
concern
is um in the borders
trafford and particularly it goes along
withington road
upper chilton air so the sort of airs
road area of
old trafford that that boundary i'm
going to try
fabiola do we know how to share screens
um
laura who is has been trying to get it
on it
should be like a green uh button in
front of you on the toolbar
okay share screen okay um i'm going to
um helen could you could you ring laura
and see whether she's managed i don't
think oh laura you are on have you
managed to get
the can we share the slides or is it
still not working
thought laura was on uh yes
laura was on because i'm sure i've
admitted laura just probably
yes laura are you able to share the
screen
i am just trying to now
so well while laura's i mean we've had
real technical problems over the last
couple of days um
so what we've been doing in um so
because it bound
because the boundary of the area
identified in manchester
is shared with trafford we
and because this is an area that we were
already concerned about
ongoing high rates of cases
thanks laura um we thought that it would
be
a really good opportunity for us to
start thinking about how we
um if you go to the next slide please to
start thinking about our public
engagement
response um focusing on this
this particular area because of the
operation
eagle and the concerns that people might
have
because of the proximity to to the area
because obviously lots of people living
in that area
will be we'll be working in in that hume
most side area or maybe get work it may
be studying at mmu
um maybe shopping in that area so it's
just really to try and make sure that
we're able to give
proper reassurance to our public but
also make sure that people understand
why we're not
part of it and we're not part of the
operation eagle because the epidemiology
the the study of the and the disease
patterns and the patterns
of behavior do not put our population
do not make our population more likely
than anywhere else in greater manchester
to have this variant and therefore it's
really is not worth
us being included because it's unlikely
to to show up in our area
from what we know at the moment about um
about the spread
so um i mean those things can change but
at the moment that's that's the
reasoning behind it
so i'm perfectly comfortable with that i
you know it's not that the
it ends with us because that's
manchester and we're trafford it ends
where it ends because of
the um the detailed knowledge and um
work that's been going on to identify
which population might be at a slightly
higher risk
and actually they've put a very big
circle around around it so
we really are right at the edge um we're
not in it
and we're it's it's of a big circle
so that's that's why we're not included
in that and so we don't have access to
the asymptomatic pcr testing
or for any additional pcr home tests so
what we're wanting to do is just make
sure that everything we
are doing and providing for our
residents is as good as it possibly can
be
and that we're able to provide the
reassurance we had
considered whether to offer additional
lateral flow testing
so the next slide in this area
for asymptomatic people and we thought
about this i mean we've been backwards
and forwards with this
but in the end we felt that it wasn't
warranted
we in trafford have been using our
lateral flow testing for people without
symptoms for people
who are in higher in settings where it
really matters
if they are positive and the the risk of
spreading diseases
is um would be the consequence of any
disease spread would be very very
significant so
it's used in cat with our care home
staff it's with you with our health and
social care staff
visiting people's homes um and working
in
in settings where it's more difficult to
control any spread
um working with more vulnerable people
so all of those people are already
in an offer for lateral flow testing and
they have regular testing
the lateral flow test we've talked about
before it's not very accurate
so you can get a false negative and
you could get a negative result and it
it's not real you you might actually be
positive
so that's why we always want it linked
to a routine regular testing twice a
week testing
and we thought it would be quite
difficult to set up a lateral flow
testing site
in the north of the borough and do a
one-off because that really
you know you you we could end up testing
a lot of people that
um got a false negative result and they
could then think that they could do
things that
you know um that they wouldn't be at
risk of spreading
disease where in fact they could still
be incubating it we also felt that it
might people might feel it was
stigmatizing and also that it might make
people feel more at risk than we believe
they are
so we believe on on balance that it
isn't worth
offering a one-off lateral flow testing
site
we what we want to do is instead make
sure that we're really supporting people
to access the testing opportunities that
we have already
if people are symptomatic and also for
those higher risk
workers to make sure that they're able
to access our lateral flow testing our
routine testing
at the town hall um and we also didn't
want
you know we're wanting to just and as i
say to give that reassurance that this
at the moment
we're not um we're not we're not seeing
additional
activity our rates are still coming down
in this area
but but we know that this particular
area
because of all sorts of other because
the impact of deprivation
has higher impact from covid and so we
really want to make sure that we're
putting everything in place that we can
to support our community
so if we if we go on to the next slide
um so what we can see here is that the
um the rates oh
this this was the slide that we were
struggling to get to get in but um
essentially this is the uh this is the
line over time eleanor that we were
looking at this morning and this is the
last
the last week data so i'll just shift
this around while you talk through it
yeah so the um the slides just are
showing
that infers with our rates which is the
msoa that's um
and old trafford and ferswood and
trafford line
we you can see that our rates have been
consistently higher than the trafford
um average rates throughout the pandemic
i mean
on occasion they've come down below but
also that they
they go up higher where as the rates go
up
as you can see there so there's the
traffic line underneath but as
in each of the times when we've had a
peak those they've come up
beyond the impact has been bigger on
every one of our peaks
particularly in the first wood area um
and then it they they are coming down
now but they're still
above the particularly the old trafford
line
is still a little bit above the line for
the borough as a whole
so that's that's the um the rationale
for us looking at these areas anyway
and we haven't found any of the new
variants in this um
yet and we hope we won't and it is
it though the increase is likely to in
and the slower
return um the slower drops are likely
because
more people doing face-to-face work more
people um
in overcrowded accommodation lower
income levels meaning that
um it's often more difficult or people
are less you know
find it more difficult to access testing
uh because they're more worried about
the consequence of a positive result
and the consequent self-isolation and
potential loss of income
so on the next slide
this is what the area that we've
identified for additional
engagement actions so we're looking at
the um
most of the cases in old trafford and
ferswood are within that highlighted
blue area so you can see it's
sort of that more or less a square
of seymour groves stratford road
upperchalton road and chilton road
so that that's the area where we're
going to be focusing our enhanced um
offer and that's in talk a lot of it is
about engaging with communities and
finding out from from people living in
the area
about what's working well for them what
isn't working so well
and how do we and how do we improve the
way that we're making offers
and how do we improve the offers we're
making in order to engage
um people better and get to get the
services that people need and want
i think one thing i'm just going to say
about trafford that's been going really
well
is that trafford has done much better
than any other borough in greater
manchester
getting access to people for support
with self-isolation and financial
support
and those grants i think and we really
do need to make sure that people
understand that those grants are
available
because i think often people think that
if it's a a grant
that it will be very difficult to get
and there are difficulties with it it's
not a perfect system because of the way
that nationally the
the the it's been set up about some of
the
um criteria those are being reviewed but
within traffic it's being given out
through
our traffic assist program and the
assumption is that when people apply
that they are eligible so we're trying
to really make it as easy as possible
for people to get that money and to get
that money quickly and we'd as i say we
are doing significantly better than
anyone else in greater manchester
so i think people need to be reassured
that if they do apply for that grant
they they are very likely to get it they
um if they
they they the criteria will be fairly
applied
and um they should be able to get that
funding
so that shouldn't you know we really
want to make sure that people are
encouraged
to apply for that so um we're putting
together
um a set we've now put together an
action plan
and i'm going to ask each of my
colleagues to talk through the elements
within that
from this meeting what we'd really like
to have your views on
is the views on our action plan then
we've also got a slide on how we'll
measure success
and on the key messages so we'd really
like you
um to give us your feedback on what's
included in the action plan
what's included in our measures of
success and what's included in
our key messaging so that we can get
that as good as possible and
we're really hoping that you will all
support us with the delivery of this
i don't know if anyone has any questions
now on operation
eagle and on our initial response or if
you want us just to go through
what the actions that people are going
to be taking
uh thanks chad dorothy have you got a
question yeah it's just about the
discussion
around um the lateral flow test you know
we talk about
the links to declaration and i know the
rates are going down in ill traffic but
we talk about stigma particularly for
communities of identity
i think that we do really need to think
again
about the messaging in relation to the
lateral flow test for everybody
and making it available for everybody in
the north area
because we do know that particularly
from being communities there is a
reluctance to
accept the vaccine and therefore if we
can
um you know encourage people to be
tested
that surely is another option that we
should be looking at as opposed to um
having the lateral flow test just for
certain categories so
what we've tried the because of the um
so the lateral flow tests
are already available to a lot of people
working in the north and a lot of them
do home tests so for example all of our
school
staff will be getting lateral flow
testing we'll be having that opportunity
through schools
we're not getting brilliant take up in
some of those groups
and so we do and we're working with them
on some of the reasons for that and some
of it is because people are worried
about
if you know if they're if they're
asymptomatic everybody's well
um and the impact it might have on other
family
household members if they're positive
and everybody has to self-isolate so
there is
there is in some we've certainly heard
some reluctance
to engaging with the lateral flow
testing because of that
the other thing i think is we do have
the lateral flow testing site
at the town hall it's not it is
a bit of a way i absolutely agree from
um from parts of old trafford
and and particularly the clifford road
area um
our worry about lateral flow testing and
mass testing is that we really do want
people to be
tested twice a week and be part of a
regular program
because if they're not part of that
regular program there is that real
danger that you do it once they think
they're fine
and of course you can pick it up that
evening so it's really trying to make
sure that we get the lateral flow
testing
targeted to the the right people that we
can we can test regularly and again all
of our care home staff
um health workers and so on are already
included
i think my my view would be that the
focus our focus should really be on
trying to make sure we get people
vaccinated
and symptomatic people tested because
that will be the things that make by far
the bigger difference
but we're certainly always willing to we
are the lateral flow testing is
something that we can think about
and certainly might be something that if
we had a significant outbreak
in a particular geographical area we
might think of doing but at the moment
we're not at that level
in old trafford we're not saying the
rates are so significant that we think
that we should be doing
mass testing of everybody we can so that
that's our reasoning at the moment
yeah i'm just thinking that um you talk
about having people tested twice a week
maybe we should get people into that way
of thinking
so that you know people are thinking
about the virus they're thinking about
getting tested and that may lead them on
to
having the vaccine i think it's
something we can definitely think about
and it's something we've been discussing
so i'll be very happy
very happy to think about that i'd like
us to start by really getting the promo
i think i would start with the people in
those higher risk settings getting
really good uptake with them
first because the consequences of some
of those people
being not being tested are greater than
for some
some other groups but absolutely i'm i'm
more than happy and i do think
one of the things i think we one of the
things we'll move on to i think is
guessing that expert having an expert
reference group within north trafford to
help advise us on all of this
and i'd really like to take some of
these conversations to that group
because what we want to do
is respond to those community needs
rather than
us make a decision here so absolutely i
think that's something that we can
really think about with this next phase
of work
about what's the role of the lateral
flow test and what do our local
communities want from it
so very very open to having those
conversations with with yourself and
others
thanks um i unless does anybody focus
yes
there is someone come on to chair but i
was going to say can i thank dorothy for
that
question and can i thank you for this
very comprehensive presentation now
it is the first time that members are
telling you today will have seen this
so when you're talking about feedback uh
can i assume that members are free to
email laura
or or helen maybe with with any feedback
they have
on this presentation absolutely
absolutely this is not meant to be the
close of it this is meant to be the
start
and any questions that they may come
come to come to
come along and and realize that they
want to ask
after this meeting today um that's great
to know that can i therefore invite
councillor newgross with his question
please
elena thank you for the presentation um
i ask it ask this question now because
the clarity on this perhaps guides our
response i
i just need to understand that that this
uh
mutation the e484k
is
combined with the ken varian it does
that not mean we all have
the worst of both worlds um with the
fact that it is
slightly more transmissible and has some
extra resistance to um
immune response um i mean it's
it's it's a variant of concern so there
are two different types of variants
of the vaccine at the moment the very
there's variance of interest and
variance of concern and
and this new one has now been identified
as a variant of concern
i think it's inevitable that we will see
these happening
you know and and it's likely i suspect
it's likely that we will have
um our response to cove it may well
involve
an annual immunization program as with
flu because flu
flu changes every year and each year um
people study the the predominant strains
that are circulating and create a
vaccine for those specific
strains so people are definitely uh
currently now working on a for
a vaccine that will work be more
effective against the 484
so it's it's um is not something we want
to see but it's not something i suppose
that we are very surprised by
seeing um and i think we have to we
i i imagine that over the um well
certainly now
by the autumn into the winter i imagine
there will be a
new version of the vaccine available in
the meantime it is definitely worth
having the vaccine for the current one
there is absolutely no reason why you
would not take the vaccine even if
even if it makes even if there is a
slight drop in effectiveness
our vaccinations both the az and the um
pfizer vaccines are so effective you
know they are really really
good vaccinations so if they are really
effective
so it is worth it even with a slight
drop in even if there was a slight drop
in the um efficacy of it
on this particular um strain it would
still be a very very good vaccine
i wasn't even questioning that i was
wondering whether we had
we could put more resource i mean i'm
going to we're going to get the action
plan a minute so i'll ask
that question at the end of the action
pan thank you thank you very much you
i don't think there are any further
questions um and i just wanted to pick
up on one thing myself
we talked about isolation grants um we
are doing very well in trafford
and as you know and i think the group
need to know
when you compare with some authorities
we're using trafford assist their
starting point is
how can we help you to get this money as
opposed to other councils that are using
their benefits sections
which are basically saying can how can
you prove to us that you deserve this
money and that is the difference in the
performance of traffic
i don't think that's worthy you know
that's to our credit and to the way
we've handled that
uh do you want to now go on and invite
people in
eleanor to to talk about the action plan
difference yes
i'll i'll do that now so um i've now
managed to lose where the
action plan is um i think
sorry helen sorry uh through your chair
i believe there is a question from
counselor
aquinola yep only a quick one it's just
a technicality because i'm tested by a
work
i'm one of those people who do regularly
and
and it's through bearer if i it doesn't
come off my home address or with
trafford
so for all the people who are being
tested who might not work in trafford
but
live in trafford would trafford get to
know
if people were um coming up positive or
not
yes yes we would so it's on your home
address
so you're imp if you've as if your
employer would get to know
as long as you've put your employer name
on on this thing and we
get to know because um it's linked back
to the residents so any resident of
trafford who's positive
we get to know about and helen can talk
more about that i'm sure
um okay so uh i've managed to lose
the screen with the um what's first on
our action plan so the data i think
we've talked about so i'm going to hand
over to somebody but i cannot now
i can't see the thing so i can't work
out who i'm handing over to ellen there
it's community hubs
so excellent so it's helen brilliant um
just to answer the question around
contact tracing um we
like elena said we get the information
about where the individual lives and
which businesses
are based in trafford where there's
positives irrelevant
of whether it's a pcr or a lfd test
and that's something we pick up we we
run um
reports every morning to ensure that we
have um and respond to any outbreaks in
our area
and that's running really well at the
moment um so that's positive news
in terms of community hubs obviously
this is joe gibson and
laura um and louise shaw's kind of
domain around the support element
but just to reassure people that as a
contact tracing team we work very
closely and ensure that our residents
who need the information
around support receive that information
so there's
support through trafford assist and
through the hubs directly
and also what we know is that blue sky
in the north so in our stratford and
old trafford hubs do well-being um phone
calls so they do ring
anyone in the area who is needing to
isolate or is clinically extremely
vulnerable at the moment as well
um and i think that's it really in terms
of the payment that's all running very
well louise
is very um you know he's collecting data
it's very responsive
um and i'm just checking my earphones
can work i'm having technical problems
which is a nightmare um but yeah so
everything is is um all linked in nicely
with the community hubs work and jo
and her team are continuing to develop
that thank you
thank you helen uh the next one on the
action areas vaccinations
is that going to be martin martin
pritchard
you're on mute elena
yes it's martin on vaccination so there
is very good news i think martin will
tell us about vaccination because we
were a bit worried about uptake rates in
that
area but martin i'm going to hand over
to you thank you elena
um um before the um
this this work about operation eagle
began
we were already having conversations
about the vaccination program
in the north trafford area and as we've
got more of the
astrazeneca vaccine which is easier to
transport between places and administer
we'd already agreed that we would have
limelight and seymour grove as
vaccination centers for the north part
of trafford so
they are things that we've already
agreed and put in place but but fit very
nicely into this uh this high level
action plan i'll pick up obviously more
of the detail when we move on to the
mass vaccination program but they are
the highlights for this part of the
agenda chair thank you
thank you martin um testing contact
and contact racing is that donna
thank you chair um i think ellen has
outlined the
the issues around lateral flow testing
um and just probably just a point that
i'm sure you're all aware of but um it's
only when we do a pcr test
that we can do the genomic sequencing
that will identify the new variants
so the lateral flow testers everyone
who's involved in them knows
um that that they aren't analyzed in the
lab they're analyzed on site so that
just the
importance about why manchester got
mobile testing units to use the pcr
offer
um as opposed to the lateral flow i'm
really
grateful for both um council a canola's
and dorothy's comment and
really interested again in just hearing
that further feedback around
the the testing and as i say we have our
national flow testing site at trafford
town hall
it's quite hard to encourage people to
come twice a week
and i think for those people who are
working in high risk occupations they
can understand that
so again utilizing the expertise of our
local residents and our
our community leaders it might be really
helpful for that dialogue about whether
there are the high risk settings from
those areas
we could be reaching out and encouraging
them to attend
thanks chair thank you donna uh
so the next one on the list is
engagement uh is that
for you nigel nigel smith
casa freeman yes that that's myself so
um
so in terms of community engagement uh
as we've explained to the board
previously
we have um we now have four neighborhood
leads
uh in in trafford uh one of those being
north uh but we'd already identified
uh the north area as alan explained as
an area where we really wanted to ramp
up our in
engagement activity because of the um
you know consistently high levels
of cases in the area so um
so we are looking to target uh our
engagement work more
in in the north area and work with the
community leaders
such as the local councillors we've
already built up some existing
uh good network of contacts in the north
we want to build on that
and do some really good uh engagement
have some good conversations with
with those local leaders um and
and the community so for example some of
the kind of things we've been doing
already are um
we have established contacts with the
faith leaders of the local mosques and
started getting out mexican and
messaging again through the friday
prayers
and through the whatsapp messaging which
they've been using
we're going to follow that up with some
conversations with with the imams at the
local mosques
we are working with
looking to work with voice of bme who um
some of you will be familiar with
they've already run previous effective
campaigns for example through things
like cervical screening
and we're looking to to work with them
and for them to kind of have direct
phone calls with
the public and also
there's another project that we've got
another example with a local school in
the area
where we're working with young people
who are from the vein community
and developing videos and messagings and
other material which they can share with
their peers
and family members so a range of
activity that we've already got in place
but we want to want to build on that
uh in terms of the business sector as
well uh colleagues in
regulatory services over the next couple
of weeks we'll do some targeting work in
this area
uh we're looking at any kind of spot
checks for local businesses but also to
offer advice and support to businesses
where they might need it and we've also
already had some contact with the
education sector
uh helen collins and colleagues have
already been regular contact and had
some initial
uh um contact this week as well to get
any feedback in terms of any current
issues
and in terms of uh with spoke previously
about community champions work so that's
something that we're
looking hopefully to roll out in the
coming weeks but
if we can get um our local champions in
the area and
uh build on the existing uh voluntary uh
offer that we've already had as well
that's something they want to to build
up and work and this is all about
really us um all this kind of strands of
the activity
is to kind of hear from the community
what the issues are
how we can support with them and sort of
collate those findings that can feed
back into the
the plan and refine it going forwards
thank you nigel can i just ask laura to
bring up the next slide
uh because i think that actually if i
remember right from what i saw before
it actually breaks down all the activity
areas and shows them exactly where we're
up to
oh it's the it's the frame no it's
carry on there was a
one am i right in thinking there was a
a slide which showed all the excuses
broken down laura
there is one so we've got a very
detailed action plan
um that we're working through internally
as a team but we're just
uh sharing the sort of headlines with
you with you here
so so it's not asking the pack that was
sent to me that's yeah
that is there well the the last the last
one on the action plan is communications
is ellie going to speak to that
uh yeah um so adding to what everybody
else has said really
um obviously it's really important that
we work with the community
and taking on comments that have been
made um about
perhaps what the barriers might be in
the area to
um essentially the basics that people
will have been hearing about you know
throughout the pandemic
um including testing um as eleanor said
um the lft testing making sure the
people who currently are
able to access that and are being
invited to taking it up and as
um pastor freeman outlined you know
there is support there for people
perhaps they're not aware of it
how do we make them aware so um
initially it's been just making people
in that area who are obviously on the
border with manchester
aware of the manchester situation
reassuring people that currently they
don't need to take any additional action
so we did quite a lot of that yesterday
and then through nigel's team
ongoing engagement with the community
how do they want to
how do they best receive information
ensuring that they're
just receiving the basics so um i know
you know we're seeing some examples
where
that sort of self-isolation um advice
timings and testing vaccination
it's just going back to basics making
sure that people in the um
community are engaged with um and it's
more of a conversation so
as eleanor said that we in we understand
the barriers and what will help
people to access and really what we need
to see the rates
you know continue to decline in that
area and so you know
there's some detail there but um make
sure that people just know that their
support there for them
and once they engage
thank you ellie um i'm going to invite
any questions if you could indicate in
the chat please
uh can we stop sharing the screen now
laura
and can i ask also that this
presentation is circulated to all
members
present today the
um the what we've got is the rest of the
presentation but we can bring it up
later is the
few the measures of success um as well
that people might be interested in but
if we start with
that one so i don't know whether people
want to look at that now or discuss the
action plan so far
first well um i know that
counselor newgross had a question on the
action plan
actually i mean i was
i hadn't actually got a question it was
uh it was more just checking that uh the
local councillors which i know are on
here are happy with the um the testing
center locations and just a query on
communication and i know it's a very
fine balance between
informing and worrying i
just the fact that that it's continue as
normal i i would say
maybe it would be a little bit more um
informative than that and say there's an
area of concern nearby and
and that we you know it is not this area
but
but but i don't know what extra things
we can ask a population to
take care on more than they already
should be
but i would just say it's a very nuanced
message
there and a question for the local
councillors to see if they're
they are content thanks cancer new gosh
i think if you look at the facebook page
the messaging we've got out there now
actually does cover that can i invite
councillor acting in police for a
question
yeah it's just um asking
where are the testing sites um
i think you said uh eleanor
the the the town hall um
are there any that are closer to
the sort of central center
of where this um you know
where where the issue that we're raising
now
um you know are we considering
sort of opening up mosques and um
you'll place it like that where it's
either because the easier that
you can get to a site and
the the more that you'll get
in terms of people going because um
it is quite it's not that easy to get to
town hall
but but there may be others that you're
already um
you know uh are working in so
it's a question really how close are the
other sites to the center of what we're
talking about now
so do you want me to answer that chair
yes please donna thank you so um just
making the distinction
between the pcr sites which are the
sites where people who've got symptoms
and they go and have a test because
they've got symptoms
um and we've got um four that our
residents access
in um trafford we've got one at the
airport which is obviously not close by
we've got one in portington we've got
one at
trafford park um just behind the
trafford hotel at trafford park
and we've got one um on chester road
just opposite the big tescos
on chester road which is called uh
trafford house sorry that's the
traffic's there
so those are the ones that people can
access for a pcr test
and of course all our residents can
order a home test if they wanted a home
test
in terms of the lateral flow those are
the ones that don't detect the different
sequencing
but those are the ones where you get the
response very quickly
and we just had the one currently
counsellor
at the traffic town hall and that was
for
staff who are in contact with extended
vulnerable people or in vulnerable
settings
in addition the lateral flow has also
been rolled out to lots of different
sites
so primary schools have them secondary
schools help them care homes have them
perhaps the point i was going to make um
was that now all
large employers over with over 50 staff
can have their own lateral flows
so they can set up their own sites um
and so as a consequence of that we're
now looking to see those employers
who've got
less than 50 whether they can um uh
attend the
traffic town hall it's always challenges
isn't it between the number of sites and
the requirements to
staff those sites and run those sites in
terms of the effect
effectiveness of numbers of people going
through and as you all know we've been
very
um lucky to work with the military on
setting up some of those sites for us so
sorry it's a bit of a complicated answer
but just wanted to give you the whole
picture yeah i mean
it it's just i think we would all accept
that
um the nearer to the sort of center
um of where we we're targeting
um you that you have the site so more
people will go it
it is just natural and i think um
you know it is something that we should
consider
in my view in in setting up you know
um for a temporary period and
you know in mosques and places like that
uh that uh easy access
you you'll you'll reach a lot more
people than
expecting people to to travel out
so to speak so it's just an observation
really it's
i'm not criticizing anybody i'm just
saying that uh
you know is there any chance of
considering that
i think it is something we're
considering um and i suppose it's trying
to get us done assess that balance
because obviously people can get home
tests as well
so lots of the people who are having
regular tests do it at home
and if you're symptomatic you can get a
test sent to your home
um as well so that not everybody has to
travel for a test
it's definitely something we'll consider
i think i think the good news at the
moment for the old trafford area
is that our rates aren't so high that
we're really worried that we're missing
lots and lots of people
and that's so it it would be more likely
that we would do it if our rates started
shooting up
and we started to see you know a lot of
cases in a small area we might then
think actually this is really worth
doing
for example the door knocking campaign
and so on so it's it's just thinking
about how we
how we give a response that's um at the
moment
if you like a proportionate response
because at the moment
i think we'll do more good in using our
time and
people's energy in promoting the
vaccination than the asymptomatic
testing so that's my
my judgment of our current situation
based on the rates we see in old
trafford
and the and the and the importance of
that vaccination offer
if we have a choice of people doing
going around and
encouraging people to get a test or
encouraging people to get vaccinated
people who haven't got any symptoms then
i would be wanting to spend my time
trying to get people vaccinated but it
is absolutely a judgment call and i
think it's one that again this is
something
that i really do want to talk us one of
as we've put in those plans
it's really talking to the local
community and to to the leaders within
that community locally
because if the testing is something that
people really feel they would absolutely
value
then that's something that we we must
consider um so it's not saying it's not
ruling anything out at this point
it's it's looking at uh as if you like
the the opportunities that we have
and the relevance uh the the relative
priority of each of them in terms of
resources
and and impact on for our community both
in terms of reassurance and outcome
absolutely i absolutely agree about the
the vaccine
you know that that is the most important
thing and
um but but it's how we actually
encourage that
uh and uh how far people have to travel
you know it does come down to to to this
particularly with a hard to reach and
that's what we're talking about people
or people who are you know um
more reluctant to to have the vaccine so
we have to make
these things as easy um and explained as
easy as possible
and so yeah it's only an observation but
i know that you're well aware of all
these things so
um yeah okay thanks counselor actually i
think it's fair to say though that
another would agree that
this is kept constantly under review and
there are twice weekly meetings which
are reviewing
at the moment i've got a question from
councillor akanola
sorry i just wanted to come in and say
agree with el eleanor that we really
need to focus on the vaccination rather
than the testing because people can
access home testing
and i'm really pleased that one of the
identified sites for vaccination is the
limelight because that's really right in
the heart of the community
and it is really important that we do
keep talking to the community leaders
because they can get messages out and
in formats that are more accessible to
people
and to come to the centers because
that's where the
more resistance is is people with the
vaccinations rather than the testing
and we need people to be vaccinated
because that's the only way we're going
to sort this thing out
um but um
yeah and the schools getting working
with the kids in the schools because
um especially secondary schools because
it's the younger people who are more
likely to be
more mixing and less concerned because
they know they
don't particularly get symptoms or
severe symptoms
and and that's where the risk of
infection can be passing it back on to
grandparents and everything else so i
just wanted to agree with elena about
the vaccinations really
and the focus rather than testing thank
you counselor
and can i thank khan for his comments in
the chat that everyone can see
uh and the positive support and
engagement you've had from local
councillors
um are there any further questions on
the action plan
i can't see any at all um
i am close to time but can i just return
back to
to martin to talk to in more general
terms about how the mass vaccination
programming traffic is going please
thank you certainly thank you chair
the the first thing i want to start off
by saying is since the last time we met
as a public engagement board
the key message from the nhs to those
people
in cohorts one to four has changed
so up until this point what we've been
saying to people is
don't contact us we will contact you
when we are organized and ready to
provide your vaccine and over the last
few days
that message has changed to if you are
in cohorts one to four
and you have not been contacted you have
not received your appointment for a
vaccination
please get in touch with the nhs either
through
the national booking line which is the
1119
sorry the 119 number or the national
booking online service or through your
local gp so that fundamental message to
people
in cohorts one to four has changed
what that reflects is it reflects the
overall
success of the programme in terms of
reaching those people
in cohorts one to four so they are just
to remind us
those people who live or work in care
homes the elderly those people aged over
70 and frontline health and social care
workers and in in trafford
and i'm going to put the same caveat i
put in all of these figures
in that because of the way in which the
national information systems have been
set up
the data that i have is based on data in
gp systems
but it takes a couple of days for that
information to get from the vaccination
center wherever it is into that gp
system so
my data is always slightly slightly out
of date
but but in trafford overall um over 89
of people in cohorts one to four
have already received their vaccine
based on the data in the gp systems of
which there's a
a data lag already built in and that's
why that message has changed because we
are now
you know getting towards those those
last
few people who have not had their
vaccine
in terms of the over 80s um 84.9
of people aged over 80 have had their
first dose of a vaccination and as i say
that is an under reported number because
of the
the time lag of the delay so 85
of our sorry 95 of our over 80s have
received a first dose of vaccination
um 93.3 of people aged over 75
have received their first house
vaccination
and just under 84 of people in category
force that's aged over 17
and clinically vulnerable so overall
from a standing start a program which is
less than nine weeks old
it's not a bad start um and what we need
to do is we need to
absolutely get on and re-contact people
who have not taken up
that offer of vaccine for for for
whatever reason
we will never get to 100 we will never
get to 100
there will be some people who are not
well enough to receive the vaccination
for example
um there will be some people for
whatever reason who decide that they
don't want to have the vaccine so we'll
never get to 100
but it's a very good start and as we
already mentioned looking through the
data and looking through the patterns of
data
we'd already last week agreed that we
need to have additional centers at
limelight and seymour grove
and i've seen that the conversation so
far and and the chat which is saying
yeah
limelight is absolutely the right place
where we should be offering
vaccinations so that's where we are in
terms of
the broad figures our message to our
networks and all of our
vaccinators is very clear at the moment
which is you should absolutely be
concentrating on
cohorts one to four and making sure that
everybody in that cohort
has the opportunity for a vaccination we
are saying
to our primary care networks that if
it's a choice of wasting
a vaccine because of some of the very
time limited nature of that
then it might be appropriate that you
invite some of those people in cohort
five if there's a danger of wasting a
vaccine
or you probably want to have a reserve
list of people in cohort five
in case some of the people from cohorts
one to four don't show up for their
appointment for
for whatever reason but the message is
absolutely clear we should still be
concentrating
on cohorts one to four because those are
the people nella will nodded me
who are most likely to be seriously ill
how are most likely to end up in
hospital and that's the reason for the
continued focus on that
um we know don't we nationally the
government set a deadline
a target of february the 15th for um
people in cohorts one to four being
vaccinated and that's on monday
and what we all are looking forward to
is the next stage of the vaccination
strategy
so is the next stage going to be cohort
five or is it gonna be cohort five and
six or is it gonna be cohort five six
and seven
um you know what what exactly is the
next stage of this and the sooner that
we are aware of that and we're all clear
about that
the better in terms of being able to
plan effectively for this
as we move down the cohorts um it is a
statement the obvious but i'm going to
say
it anyway um the numbers of people in
the cohorts get larger so there are more
people
aged 60 to 65 than there are for people
aged 65 to 70.
there are many more people aged 55 to 60
than are
you know et cetera et cetera et cetera
so the challenge gets greater as we move
down
the cohorts um but it's absolutely a
challenge that in the last nine weeks
we've
absolutely stood up to and the final
thing i just wanted to say and we've
mentioned some of this in the
conversation so far is
an absolute focus now on um and i'm
sorry i
occasionally slip into management speak
i know i do um we're absolutely moving
into a focus on
um communities with with vaccine
hesitancy is that is the jargon where
we're using on this so it relates back
to the previous conversation about
how can we encourage um those groups in
our society
for whom take-up rates are lower for
whatever reason
to take the opportunity to come forward
and have the vaccination so
um that's the the overview i'm aware of
time chair
happy to answer any questions of course
thank you
um martin a very comprehensive update as
usual are there any
questions at all for uh for martin
i don't see anything in the chat um
thank you martin uh very quickly then um
nigel have you got anything further you
want to add on uh update of
an escalation from community engagement
i can't supreme just probably the thing
just to mention is just
in terms of our work with supporting
businesses i think i might have
mentioned
at the last meeting that we were looking
to arrange
some webinars for businesses so we have
got the first of those tomorrow morning
which is aimed at
larger businesses and hopefully that's a
success which i'm sure we'll be will
we're looking to roll that out to to
other businesses
i think that's the main thing i just
wanted to highlight
thank you nigel that has been well
advertised actually i've seen the
webinar well advertised through the
trafford business bulletin and a few
other places as well
um moving on then uh to helen grant on
uh escalations from community
enforcement group if you're going to
update us with helen thank you
are you on mute eleanor
i think helen's having a few technical
difficulties there
um nigel could you assist was there
anything at all you're aware of
at all that uh any update there
sorry i'm not sure exactly what helen
was gonna provide in terms of an update
i don't know if she's provided a paper
or not she normally does but i don't
know if she has this time
there is there is no paper this time but
uh clearly uh helen is having some
difficulties
and i think she's disappeared actually
is that right fabiano she disappeared
and i can still see helen uh um
unfortunately sometimes chair
uh is just you know she's in the chat
she's stuck on mute
she says we've had the highest number of
uh reports about non-compliance
and it is still an issue and i think
eleanor would agree with me on that
and and i know that we've had a little
bit of stick
around our messaging on this but i have
to say
that um i do know that traffic is in the
business of supporting our businesses
and i want to make this absolutely clear
we're not in the
in in the area of of being vindictive or
closing down i think that's an important
message we need to get across
we're there to support but what we do
require is our business to operate in a
safe way
and would you like to comment on that at
all
yes absolutely and i think what we're
trying to do with the business
engagement is really try and encourage
people to um
to understand that we are you know our
rates are still high and we've got such
a good opportunity with the lockdown to
get the numbers down but we
we do need everyone to um to comply with
with their guidance i think we hear
quite a lot about young people
and um and obviously the risks are low
but we also see
and i know um everybody will agree with
me certainly that
we see an awful lot of young people
behaving incredibly responsibly
and being really careful not to bring
any disease home and actually some
really quite
quite significant i think levels of
anxiety among some of our younger people
particularly when they're living in
multi-generational households
so i think it is about making sure that
we we do keep giving those messages that
actually most people are compliant
most people are have are taking this
really seriously
but there are some situations that make
it very difficult for people to
to act in in the right way and some of
that is because
some businesses still haven't really
understood the impact particularly of
the new variant the kemp variant
with um with how transmittable it is and
they're still trying to encourage people
to come into work when they don't need
to
or not doing all of the things that they
could do for
making their business completely secure
and i don't know if helen wants to
comment a bit more on that but i think
we really do need to make sure that we
you know it is about all of us as our
individual behavior but it also does
our employers and the businesses also
need to really engage with this
and make sure that they are doing
everything they possibly can
to support the measures and make it
easier for people to work from home when
that when they can
and to reduce those social contacts
within the workplace as well
so i completely agree it's mainly a very
positive message but i think there is
there is some i think there's definitely
some room for improvement in some
sectors
to just make sure we that everybody
recognizes the impact
of some some things that probably before
we had the kent variant were absolutely
fine because that version of covid was
less transmittable
but now we're seeing that any it gets
through any gap really so it's making
sure that we've got everything
absolutely watertight um helena helen
collins might want to call mr echo elena
said we are very busy with businesses
and
it's kind of an unders i think what
we're spending a lot of our outbreak
control meetings doing is around
education
rather than enforcement there's a real
kind of
um lack of understanding really about
the significance of some of the key
actions businesses have to take
so that's why the webinar tomorrow is
really helpful but we are working very
hard with our businesses
to support them because it's a difficult
time for them but also to
you know encourage them to be more
inquisitive with their staff and to
build that kind of more transparent
relationships with
their workforce to be able to understand
what is happening
so yeah just to echo everything that
eleanor said really and we are seeing
numbers
uh higher numbers of outbreaks than we
had previously
thank you helen can i just before i'm
going to invite helen grant to come in
are you back with us helen
are you off mute no all right uh and uh
i just want on the outbreak control me
to give you some feedback actually
because we're on chair of governments at
springfield school
and they've had a number of outbreaks
they were subject to an outbreak
review and they have found it absolutely
reassuring
uh it has bolstered staff confidence it
has been assured them that actually
their risk assessments were okay and and
uh they've had a walk around with your
team
to look at some pinch points maybe where
they should be wiping areas more or
whatever
and so i just wanted to send that
feedback that the the work that is being
done
uh is absolutely in that area i think is
really really a credit to the authority
and a great to the staff that are
involved thank you
thank you um well
what we're looking for then from today's
meeting is any feedback members want to
supply to either helen laura
or eleanor in relation to the
presentation that was given
and the action plan and and raise any
further questions or queries you have
that way
and you can contact them directly on
email
i'm conscious of the time is there any
other business
i i don't see any so the date of the
next meeting everybody is the 24th of
february at the same time 10 a.m
can i thank you all for your attendances
today and
we'll see you all again in two weeks
time thank you very much indeed
everybody thank you